there's probably no County in America
more symbolically important to the
Democratic party than Miami-Dade
in Florida south Florida new polling
there indicates that Ron DeSantis who's
running for re-election as governor of
the state of Florida may win Miami-Dade
which is pretty unbelievable
so why how did Ron DeSantis who served
for one term as Governor of Florida
apparently shift Miami-Dade Republican
what is going on here exactly not all
disinformation we suspect Ron DeSantis
joins us tonight
governor
thanks so much hey how are you great for
coming on so you know these are just
polls but it does seem possible that you
will win Miami-Dade
uh which wouldn't have seemed possible
two years ago so what exactly is going
on here to what do you attribute there's
clearly been a shift why
I think there's a number of factors I
mean one I was the governor that was
saving their jobs their businesses and
keeping their kids in school during
covet the Democratic party opposed me on
every single one of those policies and
they wanted basically indefinite
lockdowns and school closures and that
is not good for Blue Collar people we
also have done very strong on crime when
you have the Floyd riots I immediately
called out the National Guard we were
not going to let that happen in Florida
we are a Law and Order State and they
know I'm a Law and Order Governor I
think that's important and then I also
think we reflect their values as parents
raising kids we fought Disney to make
sure that this kids wouldn't be
sexualized in elementary school by
keeping things like gender ideology out
of the classroom but yet you it's the
left that wants to put all that in there
so I think you just see Latinos down
here but really blue-collar people
generally saying we're representing them
we are standing up for them their jobs
their education their safety and their
families
so I once saw Frank Luntz who's a famous
Republican pollster tell Republican
members of Congress that they wanted to
win Hispanic votes they had to move left
you're saying you've won those votes by
moving right
absolutely and including on immigration
my first year we banned Sanctuary cities
and news media thought that that would
be not approved down here and yet
Hispanic voters in Florida had the
highest approval rating for our policy
to ban Sanctuary cities we did the
transport to Martha's Vineyard and
people thought that this was going to be
so bad and yet Hispanic voters backed me
on doing that because they understand
the border is out of control so I think
it's on all of these issues but clearly
the Republican establishment view that
you need open borders and amnesty to
appeal to Hispanic voters in the United
States is dead wrong it was wrong then
and it's clearly been proven to be wrong
now they've been saying it for 30 years
it's just amazing experiment in
democracy uh actually Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida on the eve of the
election thank you so much
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight